SPEAKER: Ladies and gentlemen,
this is your "places" call.
Places for the coming show.
(APPLAUSE)
JONATHAN GROFF: Spring Awakening
is so hard to describe.
1891 Germany. Rock music.
There's children in it.
LAUREN PRITCHARD-COBB:
The gay scene. Abortion.
The sex. The suicide.
There was never
anything like this
that's ever happened on stage.
TOM HULCE:
The controversial nature meant
that we never thought
about Broadway.
But it touched a nerve.
We became rock stars.
(CHEERING, APPLAUSE)
Getting back together after
50 years is gonna be insane.
We did it!
(LAUGHS)
For the years we worked on it,
we were rejected everywhere
and everyone thought
we were out of our minds.
When we were in previews,
we were losing money big time.
It was a disaster.
It really didn't start well.
Michael said to the cast,
"The future of this
is in your hands."
And that night something
happened in that theater.
♪ Oh, the wonder ♪
♪ I will sing ♪
♪ The song of purple summer ♪
If you were able to see
Spring Awakening
at the Atlantic Theater,
you got to see something
very special.
People were
jumping for joy and shouting.
It was totally surreal.
It felt like
we were The Beatles.
We, of course,
loved our show and loved
playing our characters,
but the real fun we had
was off-stage together.
SPEAKER 2: Through the cast
and through the opportunity
of getting to play
this character,
I had grown this strength...
and it changed my life.
♪ God is this it? ♪
♪ This can't be it! ♪
♪ Oh, God!
What a bitch! ♪
SPEAKER 3: The things
that we confront in this show
are not things
you can learn in school.
And they're things
that help people survive.
SPEAKER 4: That's kind of what
got us through it every night,
knowing how important
it was to tell that story.
SPEAKER 5:
This was not about this reunion.
This was an opportunity
to be with those kids
and see who they've become.
I would not have
survived the experience,
if it wasn't for all of you.
I learned
that dreams can come true.
(APPLAUSE)